[Music]
it's time for Friday Follies that really
follows from the follies looks a little
little little beaten up but that's okay
because we bins begin tonight let a
serious subject it shows why Samantha
bees apology for her obscene insult of
Ivanka Trump now seems fake you're not
gonna believe what she said last night
behind closed doors here's what she said
the New York Times bestselling author
and Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
is gonna tell us Raymond this was a
television awards ceremony what great I
mean yeah this is from the television
Academy okay that grants the Emmys they
gave Samantha a special award Samantha B
for her social activism lifting society
now remember this is the woman who told
Ivanka Trump you're a feckless c-word
and you should wear something tight and
low-cut so your father will change his
immigration policies she had to
apologize for that but at this ceremony
which the media was not allowed into she
said this we don't have the audio but we
have a transcript here's what she said
we spent the day wrestling with the
repercussions of one bad word when we
all should have spent the day incensed
that as a nation we are wrenching
children from their parents now it
wasn't one word it was also the context
that somehow if uncle Trump should tart
up to get her father's attention that
was never addressed at all either in the
apology or here the fact that Ivanka
Trump was actually holding up her infant
son like that was an affront to Samantha
bee she's trashed me for wearing my
cross let me hold it out for her because
it actually works against vampires she's
trash she's trashed me for that actually
do we want to play the clip just for
playback it is the front this is from
how it flows yeah we floated it that's
all right I didn't want to give it the
the the light of day but so she she
continues to be present claiming she's
sorry she wants to move it onto
political conversation who who died and
made her a head of amnesty a problem
with this is it's misogynistic she
claims to be a feminist
here she is calling a woman reducing a
woman to her genitalia with this
horrible word and it seems the network
TBS is standing by her now the president
has started tweeting naturally his
daughter was attacked here here's what
he said
why aren't they firing no talent
Samantha B for the horrible language
used on her low ratings show a total
double standard but that's okay we're
winning and we'll be winning doing so
for a long time winning is capitalized
well he wants to let you know not clear
why but I'll take it okay it's
capitalized now brian Stelter and CNN
has jumped into this and he claims the
president has gone too far
hmm watch it seems Brian like the
president's following a lot of
conservative pundits who were jumping on
this double-standard bandwagon yes he
absolutely is he's tapping into a very
potent strain of grievance politics
something that we hear almost every day
on the president's favorite FoxNews talk
shows he's happening to the idea of
conservative victimhood that
conservatives are treated in a worse way
than liberals in this case Roseanne Barr
treated worse than Samantha be they make
it seem as if the president is somehow
to blame for foul-mouthed comedians you
know believe me there were foul-mouthed
comedians nasty people saying horrible
things before Trump they will exist
after Trump the president did take her
bait a little bit here remember Samantha
B's ratings are down by almost half why
are we responding to Samantha B he's
winning on the economy he's winning on
trade he the economy is flying focus on
the substance who cares like can he
match Obama's the final year an HBO
documented
like a West Wing like an extended west
wing portrayed the national security
apparatus John Kerry Samantha Power's
and Ben Rhodes as heroes
here's a little clip of that documentary
that's what you got to make sure it'll
be harder to dismantle in the event that
we take a different term
[Music]
as came outside to try to process all
this it's a lot too much process I think
I can I can put it in the word and say I
don't know what the words are and roads
can't find the words that's after
Hillary's defeat they all thought
Hillary is gonna win and you see that in
the documentary The Boston Globe wrote
this team's professionalism empathy
pragmatic idealism are enough to make
you weep with all that has gone missing
when I focused on a Samantha Power's who
was unmasking individuals everyday
somehow over at the UN she said we have
to make it harder to dismantle meaning
the foreign policy apparatus a rondelle
gone well I'm a change TV and Cuba those
are the three benchmark things that they
celebrate in this documentary on a day
when Donald Trump has brought North
Korea to the White House
this is a hard documentary to swallow
how time has devoured what was supposed
to be the ultimate narrator I would love
sitting next to Ben Rhodes on the
sidewalk I can't speak I've got to take
a moment well I'm gonna take a moment
now all right